CBS Morning 7 30 and a CBS News
investigation is revealing the story
behind the Wagner group a Russian
private army with close ties to
President Vladimir Putin heavily
involved in the war in Ukraine our video
shot undercover offers a vivid picture
of the Wagner group's activities in
central Africa where it's accused of
propping up dictatorships in return for
minerals that help fund its paramilitary
activities around the world Deborah
patta went to Central Africa at Great
risk to get the story and here it is
has a seemingly endless supply of Hired
Guns in Ukraine but being Vladimir
Putin's attack dog requires Deep Pockets
so he relies on plundering natural
resources miles away here in the mineral
Ridge Central African Republic known as
car
in exchange Wagner provides the
mercenary muscle to prop up the
country's leader footage filmed by CBS
shows master and Russian Fighters
actually guarding the president
in movies like this bankrolled by
Ferguson Wagner portrays itself as the
savior of car
there's even a statue in the capital
honoring the paramilitary group
what Wagner doesn't say is they
effectively run this nation through
violence and a galaxy of shell companies
Usman not his real name told us he was
tortured by mercenaries after They
seized his family's gold business he's
been in hiding ever since but agreed to
travel to neighboring Cameroon to talk
to us
not here to defend the country he said
have anyone told you that it's a lie
it's packed with the government is
forged in blood the payoff unfaird
access to cars gold mines and its
forests which fund the group's criminal
activities far beyond Africa like in
Ukraine Usman tells us how else do you
explain Russia's economy remaining
unaffected despite heavy sanctions
security analyst David artosis car pays
Wagner with lucrative deals it's all
about filling the money we're talking
about billions of dollars here these
recent satellite images show the Wagner
operated in dasima goldmine in car
but exposing gold is not easy for a U.S
designated transnational criminal
organization unless
they have total control of the airport
Usman explains so it flies its gold out
of
Central African Republic Le cargo there
is a cargo plane flying between Moscow
and Bungie he says bangi CBS News
secretly recorded this Wagner cargo
plane just after it landed in the
capital they fly in and out at least
twice a week from car that plane went
dark over Africa before turning up in
the United Arab Emirates soon after
another aircraft lands there from Moscow
the planes overlap for at least eight
hours enough time to potentially
transfer cargo before heading back to
where they came from
Wagner is also plundering cir's virgin
Redwood forests through yet another
front company transporting the Timber by
Road from its base in bangi to Cameroon
the drivers hand over this document it's
like a diplomatic free pass meaning
vehicles cannot be searched
we know Wagner often marks their wood in
a special way Usman tells us so it's
easily identified with white and green
dots
CBS News secretly filmed about the
gunman guarding one of many checkpoints
they control on the timber transport
route from car to Cameroon
Wagner trucks pass through here the
Border Town of Guru bullai on route from
the Central African Republic to the port
of dwalla every single week
tons of illegal logs end up at that Port
where Customs officials seldom ask
questions we posed as buyers
is it easy to get roots from Central
African republics and to bring it
through
[Music]
very smooth the official tells us there
are no delays it's just smooth
export documents obtained by CBS News
show Wagner regularly changes the names
of front companies to avoid detection
this is you know one of the key elements
of serious organized crime whereby in
order to disguise one company they use a
proxy company it's a model repeated
across Africa allowing regulsion to
evade sanctions and rake in billions to
fund his rapidly expanding criminal
Empire and his private army fighting
Russia's war in Ukraine but CBS mornings
Deborah patter Cameroon
Bravo to Deborah Potter that's what we
mean here at CBS when we talk about
original storytelling yeah that is a
light incredibly powerful at Great risks
for herself and a very important story
boots on the ground investigating for
sure well done